- Un coup de frein brutal au REM
de l'Est, et c'est l'autorité
chargée de planifier
le transport en commun dans
la région qui met le holà.
Dans un avis qui n'est pas rendu
public, l'ARTM estime que le
projet n'entraînera qu'un petit
nombre de nouveaux usagers.
Et en période de pointe,
selon les calculs de l'autorité,
94 % de l'achalandage du REM
de l'Est sera simplement enlevé
aux services existants,
notamment la ligne verte du
métro et le train de Mascouche.
- Ça vient s'ajouter aussi aux
firmes d'architecture qui sont
parties, aux 17 ministères
du gouvernement du Québec qui
ont émis d'importantes réserves.
- Des réserves, l'organisme
Trajectoire Québec en a aussi,
notamment sur l'absence de
connexion avec la ligne verte.
Mais il fait cette mise
en garde.
- On peut pas se permettre
de jeter ce projet aux poubelles
et de passer 5, 10, 15, 20 ans
encore avec aucun projet pour
desservir l'est de Montréal.
- Avec cette sortie très
remarquée de l'ARTM, le dossier
est plus que jamais politique.
ALEXANDRE LEDUC, député QS,
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve
- Le REM de l'Est, c'est
dix milliards. Dix milliards
pour fragiliser les services
qui existent déjà, dix milliards
pour défigurer les quartiers
de Montréal avec des pylones
affreux, dix milliards pour
un projet qui ne répond
même pas aux besoins des gens
de l'est de Montréal.
CHANTAL ROULEAU, ministre
déléguée aux Transports, Québec
- Les gens le veulent ce projet,
et nous allons le réaliser.
On dit à l'ARTM : bien, il faut
refaire vos devoirs. Et voir
un peu plus loin : il faut voir
le développement, il faut voir
les entreprises qui vont
s'établir sur le territoire.
- La clé, c'est vraiment...
- Le premier ministre, lui, met
la pression sur Valérie Plante.
- On n'ira pas faire un projet
si on n'a pas l'appui de la
mairesse de Montréal. Donc,
tant qu'à moi, la balle est
dans le court de Madame Plante,
de nous présenter un nouveau
projet qui fait son affaire.
- Même son de cloche du côté du
promoteur du projet, CDPQ Infra.
Valérie Plante répète
que son administration a listé
les conditions gagnantes
pour ce projet, notamment
une plus grande implication
de la Ville et une intégration
urbaine exemplaire.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- La mairesse de Montréal et
avec nous en direct. Bonsoir.
La balle est dans votre camp, a
dit le premier ministre. Voulez-
vous le REM de l'Est comme il a
été présenté?
- Oui, on veut le projet. Mais
je ne vous cacherai pas que j'ai
été surprise d'être interpellé
par le premier ministre parce
que ceux qui ont le droit de vie
ou de mort sur ce projet et le
gouvernement du Québec et la
compagnie qui fait la
technologie. Est y croit depuis
le jour. On a décidé d'investir
500 millions de dollars dans ce
projet. En ce moment, la
question qu'on doit se poser est
comment s'assurer que ce projet
soit le meilleur? On veut que ce
soit efficace et que ça
s'intègre bien dans le milieu.
C'est ce qu'on demande parmi les
conditions gagnantes, on veut
une place autour de la table.
Il faut que la ville de Montréal
fasse parti d'un comité
conjoint, ce qu'on refuse. Et
pour moi, c'est un problème
parce que la compagnie, son
expertise et le train. Et nous
laver, c'est l'intégration
urbaine. Il n'est pas question
que le train arrive et qu'après,
on s'occupe des quartiers et de
l'architecture.
- Vous dit au premier ministre
que vous le voulez et que vous
voulez avoir une place autour de
la table avec les gens de la
caisse de dépôt, qui sont les
maîtres d'oeuvre du projet.
Est-ce que vous le voulez de la
façon dont les dessiner?
Le REM de l'Est, après Honoré-
Beaugrand, et en parallèle avec
le métro de Montréal. Ce qui
fait dire que ça va fragiliser
le métro de Montréal. On
pourrait arrêter le REM de l'Est
à cette station de métro.
- Ça m'embête parce qu'en ce
moment, dans les conditions
gagnantes, il y avait un comité
aviseur qui travail et doivent
remettre leur rapport
prochainement. Se sont penchés
sur plein d'enjeux. Je ne veux
pas me substituer au
gouvernement du Québec,
mais on doit prendre en
considération tout ce qui va
ressortir de ce rapport. Pour ce
qui est de l'ARTM, je pense que
le gouvernement du Québec doit
entendre ce que sa société
d'État a à dire. Ces drapeaux,
il faut les entendre, il faut
pouvoir travailler avec.
Je réitère que les deux
conditions, celle d'être autour
de la table, ce n'est pas un
petit détail. C'est vraiment
important parce que ce projet
doit en être de transport et
d'intégration. Le deuxième
élément qui me chicotte,
on n'a pas d'informations là-
dessus.
- Vous avait dit à Monsieur
Legault que vous le voulez et
que vous lui renvoyez la balle,
de vous faire une place à la
caisse de dépôt pour améliorer
le projet. Vous dites qu'on peut
l'améliorer, il y a des détails
qu'on ne connaît pas encore. Il
y a un comité qui doit donner un
rapport sur la portion René-
Lévesque en hauteur.
N'êtes-vous pas inquiète qu'on
fasse deux voies parallèles et
qu'on affaiblisse la STM et le
métro de Montréal?
- C'est pour ça que quand l'ARTM
soulèvent des drapeaux, il faut
les entendre. Ça fait parti des
préoccupations qui doivent être
entendues par le gouvernement.
La ville de Montréal autour de
la table, pour l'instant, je
n'ai pas grand pouvoir. J'ai mis
500 millions pour montrer
l'importance du projet. Vous
avais raison que ça pourrait
avoir des impacts, mais il faut
le regarder et répondre aux
questions. Je veux de
l'ouverture et je veux être
autour de la table. Je ne veux
pas que ce soient les
montréalais qui se retrouvent
avec la facture totale et qu'on
fasse des aménagements après le
train.
- Est-ce que la caisse est prête
à vous faire une place autour de
la table?
- Je les ai rencontrés vendredi
dernier et c'était non.
On passe un train, ça commence
en premier et après on va faire
les aménagements. Si on écoute
la population, l'intégration
urbaine, ils le veulent, mais
ils veulent garder leur qualité
de vie. Ils veulent que la vie
des quartiers et le patrimoine
architectural demeure fort.
- Est-ce que Monsieur Legault va
vous aider?
- Je l'espère. C'est le souhait
que je lui ai partagé parce que
je veux que ce projet avance.
- Avec un rapport défavorable,
Monsieur Legault pourrait dire
que c'est trop compliqué et
comme ça au panier pour
l'instant.
- C'est une possibilité. Mais je
pense qu'il ne faut pas faire
ça. Il y a tellement de
possibilités. Un projet de cette
ampleur, on veut cet
investissement et on veut que ce
soit un lègue pour tous.
- Merci beaucoup. On va en
reparler à notre demi